more on Germany's new export hits were
joined by Felix matters from the
Institute for applied ecology here in
Berlin now German installation panels in
Dubai how do you explain that a German
mid-sized family company managed to
carve out of that kind of niche for
itself well Germany is a cold country
and we have a longer tradition on
insulation to save energy and because of
this technology was developed technology
has improved and now technology is
exported as a certain logic behind and
of course it's also being used here at
home in Germany to keep the cold out
however insulation is an important part
of Germany's energy revolution the
government hopes to save heating costs
of some eighty percent by 2050 that's
quite ambitious but a study which we're
going to see now it states that
insulated houses can actually expect a
drastic reduction of their heating costs
over a period of 20 years from an
initial hundred and seven thousand euros
down to just about 20,000 other studies
however say the opposite as a bit
confusing so who's right the first of
all we have to consider that thirty
percent of the final energy demand in
Germany comes from buildings and fifteen
percent of the overall greenhouse gas
emissions and if we want to cut
greenhouse gas emissions there's no way
to bypass insulation and the key
question when installation is what is
your assumption on future energy prices
because its capital intensive you have a
lot of front investment and so ended
there is a long lifetime and so the key
question is what is your assumptions on
the future energy prices and that gives
you the result in terms of how efficient
this is in economic terms now let's say
that energy prices are rising in the
future what kind of insulation do you
think is best for a house that depends
very strongly from the building's
because we need to optimize the heating
system and the insulation and that will
that will result in very different
technologies for different buildings and
that is one of the key drivers of
innovation in this field now what about
a health
a Spectre there is a bit of a
controversy here in Germany because we
use for the cladding process styrofoam
which can be poisonous is also easily
inflammable all in order to save energy
costs it's depending on the proper
building construction construction work
and if this is done properly and if the
insulation is probably optimized with
the heating system there will be no
major health systems or other problems
that are exemptions at the moment and
will be exceptions in the future now who
is actually carrying the costs for such
an installation process there are two
sources the first is there's a certain
payback by the air base saved energy
costs and secondly we give major
incentives from the state budget to
enable this long-term renovation process
because we have to bear in mind the the
modernization cycle is about 30 years
and there are certain windows of
opportunity opportunities which are
quickly closing and therefore the state
gives major incentives okay linux mattes
thank you very much for this
you